중동에 흔들릴 때마다 꼭 나오는 말이 있습니다.
그러면 중동산 말고 미국산 원유를 더 사오면 되는 것 아니냐?
겉으로 보면 꽤 그럴듯합니다.
미국은 세계 최대 산유국이고
쉐일 혁명 이후 원유 수출국으로 완전히 바뀌었습니다.
한국 입장에서도 중동 의존도를 줄이고
미국산 원유를 더 들어오면 공급망도 안정되고
미국과의 통상관계에도 도움이 될 수 있을 겁니다.
그런데 여기서 질문을 조금 바꿔봐야 합니다.
미국산 원유는 지금도 살 수 있습니다.
하지만 문제는 그 원유가 한국 정유공장에 맞느냐입니다.
원유는 생수처럼 브랜드만 바꿔 사오는 물건이 아닙니다.
어떤 원유는 가볍고 맑고 어떤 원유는 무겁고 찐득합니다.
그리고 어떤 원유는 황해졌고 어떤 원유는 불순물이 많습니다.
정유공장도 마찬가지입니다.
아무 원유나 넣으면 같은 휘발유와 경유가 나오는 맞는 기계가 아닙니다.
한국은 오랫동안 중동산 원유에 맞춰 정유산업을 키워왔습니다.
중동산 원유는 한국까지 가져오고
비교적 수월하고 초대형 유조선으로 한 번에 많이 실어올 수 있었습니다.
그리고 국내 정유공장들도 그 원유를 처리하는 방식에 익숙했습니다.
평소에는 이것이 장점이었죠.
하지만 중동정세가 흔들리고 호르무즈 해업이 불안해지는 순간
이 장점은 그대로 약점이 됩니다.
원유 수송의 상당 부분이 좁은 해업에 묶여있다는 사실은
한국 에너지 안보에 구조적 부담이라는 겁니다.
그래서 한국은 이미 원유 수입선을 조금씩 바꿔왔습니다.
2016년 한국의 중동산 원유수입선은
원유 수입 비중은 86% 수준이었지만
2025년에는 69.6%까지 내려왔습니다.
반대로 미국산 원유 비중은
2016년 0.21%에서 2025년 16.3%까지 올라왔습니다.
숫자만 보면 방향은 분명합니다.
한국은 중동 의존도를 낮추고 있고
미국산 원유는 그 빈자리를 채울 중요한 후보가 되고 있습니다.
하지만 중동산을 덜 사는 것과
미국산으로 완전히 갈아타는 것은
다른 문제입니다.
국제 원유 시장에서 원유를 구분할 때
중요한 기준은 크게 두 가지입니다.
하나는 밀도입니다.
API 지수라고 부르는데
API가 높으면 가벼운 원유, 낮으면 무거운 원유입니다.
다른 하나는 황 함유량입니다.
황이 적으면 스위트 원유, 황이 많으면 사화 원유라고 부릅니다.
이걸 쉽게 정리하면
가볍고 황이 적은 원유는 깨끗하고 정지하기 쉽습니다.
무겁고 황이 많은 원유는 까다롭지만
잘만 처리하면 고부가 가치의 제품을 뽑아낼 수 있습니다.
그리고 여기서부터 한국의 고민이 시작되는 겁니다.
한국 정유 공장은 오랫동안 중동산 중진류를
잘 처리하도록 발전해 왔습니다.
그런데 미국산 쉐일 오일은 정반대의 성격에 가깝습니다.
중동산 원유가 조금 무겁고 찐득하다면
미국산 쉐일 오일은 훨씬 맑고 가벼운 원액에 가깝습니다.
그 자체로 나쁜 건 아닙니다.
오히려 품질은 좋은 거죠.
문제는 한국 정유 공장의 입맛과 딱 맞느냐입니다.
중동산 원유는 대체로 무겁고 황이 많은 성격을 갖습니다.
물론이죠.
물론 중동산 원유가 전부 똑같다는 뜻은 아닙니다.
하지만 한국이 오랫동안 많이 처리해온 원유는
중질 고유황 계열에 가까웠습니다.
그런데 이게 꼭 나쁜 것만은 아니죠.
이런 원유는 상대적으로 가격이 낮게 형성될 수 있습니다.
그리고 정유사가 좋은 고도화 설비를 갖고 있으면
이 원유를 분해하고 정제해서 휘발유, 경유, 항공유 같은
비싼 제품을 뽑아낼 수 있습니다.
한국 정유 산업은 바로 이 지점에서 경쟁력을 키워왔던 겁니다.
그런데 미국산 쉐일 오일은
성격이 다릅니다.
가볍고 황이 적고 비교적 깨끗합니다.
원유 자체만 보면 분명 좋은 기름입니다.
하지만 문제는 너무 가볍다는 데 있습니다.
쉐일 오일을 많이 넣으면 휘발유나 나프타 성분은 많이 나올 수 있지만
한국 정유사들이 중요하게 보는 경유나 항공유 같은 중강유부는
생각만큼 나오지 않을 수 있습니다.
원유의 성격이 바뀌면 정유 공장의 수율이 바뀌고
생산되는 제품 구성이 달라지며 수익 구조도 흔들릴 수 있습니다.
여기서 중요한 건 시장 수요입니다.
정유사는 단순히 휘발유만 많이 만들면 되는 회사가 아닙니다.
경유는 물류와 산업에 연결되고 항공유는 항공운송에 연결되며
나프타는 석유화학 산업의 원료가 됩니다.
어떤 원유를 넣느냐에 따라 이 제품들의 비율이 바뀌고
그 비율이 시장 수요와 맞지 않으면 원유를 싸게 샀더라도
전체 수익성은 나빠질 수 있습니다.
그래서 정유사들은 원유를 고를 때 가격표 하나만 보지 않습니다.
이 원유를 넣으면 시장 수요가 낮아지고 전체 수익성은 낮아질 수 있습니다.
이 원유를 넣으면 어떤 제품이 얼마나 나올지 기존 설비를 얼마나 조정해야 할지
다른 원유와 섞었을 때 안정적으로 돌아갈지까지 함께 봅니다.
같은 배럴이라도 정유 공장 안으로 들어가면 결과가 달라집니다.
원유는 단순한 원료가 아니라 정유 공장 전체의 운전 조건을 바꾸는 변수입니다.
그러니까 미국산 쉐일 오일의 문제는 품질이 낮다는 것이 아닙니다.
오히려 너무 깨끗하고 너무 가볍기 때문에
기존 한국 정유 시스템과 맞추는 과정이 필요하다는 뜻입니다.
아주 순수한 알코올만 있다고 생각하면
좋은 위스키가 되지 않는 것처럼 가벼운 쉐일 오일만으로는
한국 정유 공장이 원하는 균형을 만들기 어렵습니다.
그래서 결국 답은 대체가 아니라 블렌딩입니다.
미국산 쉐일 오일을 제대로 쓰려면
더 무거운 원유와 섞어야 합니다.
이론적으로는 베네수엘라 초중진류가 떠오를 수 있습니다.
미국산 쉐일 오일이 가장 가벼운 쪽이라면
베네수엘라 원유는 가장 무거운 쪽에 가깝기 때문입니다.
하지만 현실은 간단하지 않습니다.
베네수엘라 원유는 너무 끈적하고
금속 성분과 산성도 문제가 있습니다.
그래서 설비 부담이 큽니다.
그래서 현실적으로는 캐나다, 브라질, 앙골라 같은 원유가 함께 거론됩니다.
캐나다산 중진류는 미국산 경진류와 궁합이 좋지만
북미 안에서 먼저 소비되는 구조가 강해서
한국까지는 안정적으로 오기 쉽지 않습니다.
브라질산 원유는 적당히 무겁고
서아프리카산 원유는 미국산 쉐일 오일에서
부족해질 수 있는 중간 유분을 보완하는 데 의미가 있습니다.
결국 한국이 필요한 것은 미국산 원유 하나가 아니라
미국산 원유를 제대로 섞어줄 환상의 짝꿍 원유입니다.
그런데 여기서 또 하나의 문제가 남습니다.
원유의 성격만 맞추면 끝날까요?
아닙니다.
원유는 바다를 건너와야겠죠.
중동산 원유는 초대형 유조선에 한 번에 많이 싣고
비교적 익숙한 항로로 한국까지 들어올 수 있습니다.
반면 미국 걸프만에서 한국으로 오려면
파나마오나를 통과하거나 희망봉을 크게 돌아야 합니다.
파나마오나는 진흠길이지만 동시에 병목 구간입니다.
가뭄으로 수위가 낮아지면
통학량이 줄고 대기시간과 비용이 늘어날 수 있습니다.
이 지점에서 중동산과 미국산의 리스크는 성격이 달라집니다.
중동산 원유는 호르무즈라는 지정학적 리스크를 안고 있습니다.
전쟁, 봉쇄, 군사 충돌 같은 문제가 가격과 운송을 흔듭니다.
반면 미국산 원유는 파나마오나라는 물류 리스크를 안고 있습니다.
운하 수위, 통행 슬롯, 대기시간, 통행료가 비용에 반영됩니다.
어느 쪽이든 한국 입장에서는 결국 물가와 산업 비용으로 돌아옵니다.
게다가 VLCC 문제도 있습니다.
한국은 중동산 원유를 대량으로 들여오면서 초대형 유조선 운송에 익숙해져 있습니다.
하지만 파나마오나에는 선박 크기 제한이 있어
일반적인 VLCC가 자유롭게 통과하기 어렵습니다.
미국 걸프만 항만도 수신 문제 때문에 VLCC가 직접 접안하기 어려운 곳이 많습니다.
결국 더 작은 배를 쓰거나 환적을 하거나 더 먼 길을 돌아와야 합니다.
원유 가격만 보면 괜찮아 보여도 한국 도착 가격은 달라질 수 있다는 겁니다.
그렇다면
지금까지 내용을 들어봤을 때
한국은 중동산 원유 의존도를 줄여야 할까요?
그렇습니다.
줄여야 합니다.
호르무즈 리스크가 반복되는 상황에서
중동 의존도를 그대로 두는 것은 위험한 선택입니다.
특히 한국처럼 에너지 수입 의존도가 높은 나라는
특정 지역에 과도하게 묶여 있으면 국제정세가 흔들릴 때마다
물가와 산업 전체가 영향을 받게 됩니다.
하지만 미국산 쉐일 오일 하나로
중동산 원유를 그대로 대체할 수 있다고 보면 안 됩니다.
원유는 나라 이름만 바꿔서 사오면
끝나는 물건이 아니기 때문입니다.
정유 공장에 맞아야 하고 시장이 원하는 제품이 나와야 하고
한국까지 들어오는 물류비까지 계산을 해봐야 합니다.
그래서 이 문제의 답은 단순히 미국산을 더 사자가 아닙니다.
더 정확한 답은 한국이 여러 종류의 원유를 섞어 쓸 수 있는 인프라를 갖추는 겁니다.
가벼운 원유와 무거운 원유를 섞고 깨끗한 원유와 묵직한 원유를 섞고
중동산과 미국산, 브라질산과 사와프리산까지 조합을 해도 흔들리지 않는 정유 시스템이 필요합니다.
동시에 호르무즈가 흔들려도 파나마 운하가 막혀도
특정 항로 하나에 모든 비용이 몰리지 않도록 물류망도 더 유연해져야 합니다.
앞으로 중요한 것은 어느 나라 원유를 사오느냐만이 아닙니다.
한국이 그 원유를 얼마나 잘 섞고
얼마나 안정적으로 들여오고
얼마나 효율적으로 정지할 수 있느냐입니다.
미국산 쉐일 오일은 분명한 대안입니다.
하지만 답은 미국산 하나가 아닙니다.
답은 블렌딩입니다.
그리고 그 블렌딩을 견딜 수 있는 한국의
에너지
인프라입니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.